[Music]
all right fam we haven't talked about
Chinese news in a minute so we're going
to talk about some China China China all
right so um Chinese parents were
mourning the death of their son so in a
way to cope with it they actually turned
to AI to digitally resurrect their dead
son and give him a speech or a send off
that he would say to them at this
funeral wow and I find this very
interesting was it very touching what
what if it was real and they're like you
[__] forc me to do be a doctor
I didn't want to be a doctor I wanted to
be a [__] trapeze guy at the circus
and they're like pulling the wires how
do you turn this [__]
off like it's so perfectly programmed
yeah and then the I like oh this fo had
a lot of resentment let me tell you got
all his traumas so
this is interesting because there words
that obviously this late son had never
spoke but um obviously through
artificial intelligence they got him to
say these things and it says quote I
know you're in great pain every day
because of me and feel guilty and
helpless even though I can't be by your
side ever again my soul is still in this
world accompanying you through life wow
I would have been like that is not my
son [__] reprogram that AI also feels
very general like a greeting card
it's interesting right it is interesting
like that's that's a unique way to cope
I don't know if they have it but I
almost rather have like your fondest
video and then play that at the FI like
a compilation yeah compilation or maybe
even just like a raw just a raw clip of
something they always said that you
captured that you just like just the
Classic Conan O'Brien sty where it's a
frozen picture and the mouth's moving
yeah yeah yeah so good let him have some
dignity with the little and then like
you have like President Bush's voice
yeah
yeah I can imagine the extremity of this
it's like you know maybe you haven't
spoken to your child in a long time so
then you create this Ai and it's like
I'm sorry for that fight we had it was
my fault I want you to know it was never
your fault you know what I mean you like
put into your kids words things that
like will help you cope but maybe is not
necessarily like their truth but the
weird part is you're inputting what they
would say exactly cuz it makes sense
when you visit the tombstone and then
you say what you have to say
but it's weird like but this is what he
would have said back yes Dad I was wrong
the whole time you know it's like you
know it would be cool if it's like was
this on Star Wars where they have like a
hologram of that [__] and then
they have a program to that personality
so they can say they would say what they
that you that that they probably would
have said yeah but they always put
disclaimers in those things they're
always like I'm only able to say a
couple different things so ask me a yes
oral question or like you know what I
mean but I think that's what they should
do at the at the tombstone the grave
like in the future they can AI like
program
you probably get a huge compilation of
like like they could actually do it to a
life vlogger like if if you if you've
been recording yourself from like
[__] teens to all the way to like 60
right let's say you died a little early
at like 61 or whatever and your family
members are like man what would what
would dad say let's go let's go to the
uh uh uh let's go to the grave and ask
him and then you hit up the [__]
grave Ai and he comes out you going be
like
Dad all right so like I really like
Taylor but then like Taylor like she's
like I don't know she's kind of a [__]
but then there's this other girl
Michelle and like she's kind of cool but
she's [__] ugly what do you think I
should do and then Dad would be like all
right this is what you do and he's
programed to answer you so if he's like
you he's like first of all you need to
jack off you don't know what you're
going to want what you want to do you
got to think clear good boy yeah be the
good boy it's all like the audio is
super loud at the cemetery way too
they're like who the
[__] step one jack off clear your mind
oh that's just dead Joe again yeah oh
geez dead Joe goes off if if the wind
hits it I guess I guess in a way they
still kind of have that like with
historical figures you can ask like Chad
gbt to talk to you like it's them I mean
but they're only going to answer you
like basically just a different word
form of what Wikipedia would tell you
information of so yeah same deal I guess
well I mean in this situation though
this this dude woo and his wife have
joined a growing number of Chinese
people turning to aite Tech to create
lifelike avatars of their departed and
ultimately woo wants to build a fully
realistic replica that behaves just like
his dead son but dwells in the virtual
reality quote once we synchronize
reality and the metaverse I'll have my
son with me again I can train him so
that when he sees me he knows I'm his
father do you feel like that's good for
mour I just say cope harder [__] I
don't I don't think it is cuz that's
like you're not letting go cuz also when
you are in morning you're also not
making the best decisions anyway so like
I wouldn't advertise products like that
to people that are in that exact state
of mind cuz like it if you were to zoom
out in the next like 5 years for this
this couple like would that be the best
move for them no because I watch
Inception and you know how he kept her
in the memory it's to you're not you
can't move on yeah but I also watched
Wedding Crashers and will frell just
[__] funeral crashes cuz he knows
that [__] are going to be easier then
so it's like if there's a company that
stands to profit over people and their
immoralities yeah yeah yeah that's true
a great point one way that I can see it
working and being helpful is if like you
just you were kind of numb from a a
loved one's death and you couldn't feel
anything and you're just kind of
struggling with like how it got you so
stunned and then if you were to do that
and you could face to face like speak to
the person a simulation and that breaks
you and then you cry and you release I
could see that being helpful I could
also see and this is very dark and
extreme but let's say like you uh lose
your child and then you have no will or
reason to live after that so your next
thought maybe is like exiting the world
yourself but if you have a digital
companion and verion which is a very
fake and unrealistic world but you can
exist with that who gives a [__] if it's
not hurting anybody else that's true
like who are we to keep people from
getting it if yeah you know what I mean
that low already do you want though low
recognize low are you trying to go
somewhere else like get another
relationship like go heal your wounds
like what are you trying to do I mean I
think in this guy's case he just wants
his son with him always it ain't and I
know it's
weird sentiment like yeah you love your
son like crazy but let go but yeah you
got to you got to let go you got to like
more than cuz I feel like that would
torture the family right exacerbates the
pain and then holding on to this hope
that will never happen yeah well in a
weird way ai's making it happen right
like imagine if something that'll never
be your son cuz you know when you see
like
not exaggerates thank you it's a
extracurricular so you know how
extal okay Excalibur is a cool ass
Hotel what's the question what's up with
that did you know that you can take a
room that has a bathtub next to your bed
no way so it's not even in the bathroom
it's like in the whole room you could
take a bath take two steps and go inside
your bed here I got to check it out wet
so you remember movies like U like
minority or port or whatever right and
then Cruz when he has like that [__]
emotional whatever he always plays that
digital memory and it's a Memory it's
the same thing happening over and over
and they're like stuck in the past but
that's real that's what I'm saying a
video is different than AI stuck on that
same thing but he's not like checking in
with his kid who's like giving I like
bubblegum like buum Cy candy oh that's
my son oh wow my baby boy boy yeah how
old was his son di when they died uh
Excalibur no like how2 does Excalibur
have a movie theater or and maybe I'm
out yeah it's it's just different when
it's not even real it's I I do like the
wisdom thingy though like like let's say
if it was like Bruce Lee you know and
then you got all the [__] you got all
the personality traits the films you you
hear stories from let's say it's like
Bruce Lee like so if you got a Bruce Lee
AI I'm out of here have a safe FL
nothing personal but yeah whatever what
what a [__] reference what a weak
reference will can we change it to
Willis all right Bruce Willis we
reference hey Merry Christmas
[__] see you later later I love
you guys love hey we're not meeting till
January January right y Happy New Year
too all right happy New Year whether
it's Bruce Lee [__] say FL confus Ed
cut all this sentimental saying goodbye
stuff out so it just looks like he's an
[__] no no no no I I just didn't
appreciate that reference I'm out of
here so overrated Jackie Chan
forever
whether it's Bruce Lee oh my God whether
it's [__] Spartacus anybody right so
like you create a profile of this person
he's a Ai and you can have a meeting
with
them and then they give you
advice so it's like a master class is is
that so unlike creating a version of
another cuz they're also real people
maybe you didn't give birth to them but
they're still like yeah without their
permission recreating them to like
anyway yeah yeah but imagine if we can
do that like at a library so instead of
pulling out a book you just pull out
Socrates and you be like hey soccer hom
so they're only allowed to speak on
things that they've spoken of before
they can't generate new thoughts I think
that's the difference that's the
difference is you going to talk to like
a historical figure they're not going to
be like oh I was depressed I killed
myself it was tough like they're not
going to I would I would love to have
ARA's peanut butter cup even though I
never tasted it before yeah think be
silly you got to upload you got to do a
little hack to do that but like I think
what will be cool is you do that for the
for people that maybe we could create a
pretty accurate profile for but also for
family members that like you're just
like oh can we consult the Oracle
Grandma you know and then it's like
great grandma would know what to do and
then you ask great grandma what should
we do and then AI great grandma goes
y'all need to stop bickering you need to
be a good family stop being a [__]
dumbass bro you wonder where it gets
Danger
when you have people like let's say that
somebody offered themselves and they
left behind a journal and they scan the
whole [__] loaded into an AI and they go
why did you do it well and it could
answer because it it's Advanced enough
to learn like dude what if it took all
the information from that person that
already passed and they figured out
their personality through AI learning
yeah like combined public and private
records just to be like what was the
motive like why did you do it what you
created that without the person dying it
and then you ask them like how accurate
is this AI to how you would answer how
you are thinking to test it to test it
and then like if they can syn close to
the answers oh damn that means they got
really close I bet that's realistic
right because it's based on the data
that you have so if this for this couple
they don't have the enough data to be
able to to produce um an AI That's
accurate to their son but something like
a journal that's like deep
thought that that would make a lot more
sense but you would need all the
evidence for an accurate sing like what
if you like didn't have one page of a
journal entry that that person
emotionally ripped out because they
didn't want to express that that was the
core thought that would change
everything but then it goes back to the
whole thing of like you got to just let
it go right yeah you have to it goes
back to that I think that's what it is
when it comes to death that's the point
of death yeah because you know obviously
that's that's the reason why human life
is valuable right is like exactly that's
where the value comes in yeah and and
that's why we have to do everything we
can to try to like you know your son
like [__] you're like you know what I'll
just treat my AI son
better cuz it's like a red I don't
really care about you you can become a
better father you know what I mean you
have a second chance AI
kid get the [__] out of here too late
you didn't learn your lesson right I
don't know that's you got to Value what
you have right now yeah so what happened
in this thing forget it dude dude can't
be coming with all these [__] hoes
and